it really took more faith than i even
thought i had
people who are religious think their
religion is right and everybody else is
wrong
today i have completed your religion for
you and i've perfected my favor on you
and i am satisfied with islam as a
religion for you but at the same time
he managed to keep his relationship with
god closer than ever imagine a cat
he's got his claws on you whatever he
can take
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum welcome to a better
career and sisters and dear friends hope
you guys are well before i start i want
to praise allah subhanahu wa tala the
most merciful the most trust or praise
is glory
oops gratitude belongs
now as you guys know the reaction videos
we try to bring you current affairs and
try to learn things out of it and how do
we and try to connect them to the quran
and the sun and see what benefits we can
get and what lessons we can learn
from whatever it may be alhamdulillah
now in this video um i saw it from the
dean's show
and i thought the intro has covered it
that's good that's brilliant he's
covered i'm sure it came with some good
beneficial reminder
um and i thought maybe i didn't watch
the whole thing but i i
come from a different angle in the
context of uh when i watch nasty i
didn't know nastely actually did the
actual filming yeah so he's done the
filming and as you know we've done
videos from us daily before as well uh
giving like a bit of an asia etc
um and in this one i found it very
interesting what we're gonna do guys
is because i found it interesting
because steve harvey you know i know of
him i watched some of his stuff
i need to see him a man of principles he
just seemed a man where
he has a lot of islamic values you know
you know
conservative but you can see you know
there was a video that i was watching
off him of some
girl saying you know what men some guys
are scared of my dad no
no guys want to date me and he was like
good that's how it should be it shows
you that these guys are not
not they're not good for you so i have
seen these little traits in him let's
get straight into the video i want to
long this video
out and there's a few lessons i want to
learn because there's something that was
said there
which i found a little bit troubling but
in all
the video is brilliant and we asked
allah to guide steve harvey let's go and
show so this is
as you can see on the screen him and his
wife and at first i thought i was like
yo
steve have you a muslim you know like
you know you'll hear all these rappers a
muslim but anyway let's carry on here we
go
today i want to tell you about a guy you
may know him for his comedy you may know
him for his mustache but today
i want you to know him for his religion
hey i'm steve harvey stand up comedian
entertainer television host family man
but most importantly i happen to be a
man of faith steve is a very successful
guy
he has made more money than he ever
thought he has become
more than he ever thought but at the
same time he managed to keep his
relationship with god
closer than ever why did you not lose
faith as you became
more successful if i
could make myself successful i would
have done it a long time ago
i would have skipped so many of the
lessons i had to learn but it's not that
it's a process
success and happiness is a process man
and in this process
i was very aware of the amount of faith
that was needed and as a matter of fact
it really took more faith than i even
thought i had
see oftentimes people who are religious
think their religion is right and
everybody else is wrong
there is only one way to god
but steve's faith is unique because it's
really not about that
there's no one one way to heaven no one
way to paradise
it's like television now it's over 800
channels of cable and they're all pretty
entertaining so i'm pretty sure man that
to get to heaven there's got to be more
than one round
because somebody watching another
channel or taking another channel than
you they still getting entertained and
they probably still getting heavy
[Music]
this isn't just doc steve lives by these
words she has
three sons two of them he gave them
christian names like broderick
and one of them he gave a muslim name
ali
as a sign of respect and appreciation
for the muslim religion
and the muslim culture i named him ali
because i knew i knew
that he might be different from you and
you have no problems with it no
because when you come here you
understand islam is a religion of peace
why you got a problem with peace
what steve did reminds me a lot of this
mosque this mosque in abu dhabi
belongs to people in the islamic faith
but as a sign of tolerance to the
churches next to them
they renamed the mosque to mary mother
of jesus mosque can you imagine
a mosque with the name jesus on it yeah
the world could use a little bit more of
that
a whole lot more sins so guys as as you
can see
uh hamdullah beautiful video it's it's
it's it's a it's it's a beautiful video
in the context
of you can see that he's open he's
respectful um and subhanallah like the
these are the people like subhanallah
allah subhanahu wa tala tales in surah
montana verse eight
all that does not forbid you from being
just and kind to those who do not fight
you
account of your on your faith because of
your faith because you're a muslim
and don't kick you out your houses allah
makes it very clear and this
this verse is abrogated yeah this verse
is clearly telling you that you should
be kind and just to the non-muslims
so for example um when he's talking
about tolerance and stuff like that
it's all good and alhamdulillah for them
to wear the his wife to wear the hijab
and for him to you know where they're
not in the islamic garment you know it's
more like you know the
the government of the culture there it's
it's it's
it's heartwarming it's it's good it's
good to know and the prophet salallahu
has his cross his uncle was a
non-muslim you know and he had uh people
like for example non-muslims subhanallah
who's worked in islamic
empires before uh had high positions in
the islamic empire so this myth
should be debunked however there is
something here which i want to touch on
and nastily has mentioned this before
and we need to make something really
care brother and sisters yeah and
hamdullah sometimes what happens is
when we see these things happening uh
what happens is we
get into this whole the um how can i
explain
the whole lovey-dovey thing yeah okay
yeah looking we all held hands and
look just because we islam has tolerance
towards other religions
yeah you are not allowed to force your
religion in sura verse 25 6
it says that there is no compulsion
religion truth is clear from falsehood
so we need to understand that there is
no compulsion religion when the islamic
empire was expanding
they were not allowed to force their
religion yes
they would expand the empire's expanding
and they were christians and jews and
uh certain people living under their
banner however
the force of religion was haram it's not
allowed there is no compulsion in
religion
and you can live in peace where the
prophet peace be upon him lived with the
christians and the jews in medina
and they were even though some of them
were hostile towards him he lived in
harmony
now to live in harmony and to say that
there is harmony one in harmony to the
truth
that is not correct because allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala says in surah maidah
verse 3
today i have completed your religion for
you and i have perfected my favor on you
and i am satisfied with islam as a
religion for you so it's very clear
for us to say that there is one way and
this whole notion
is nothing but devil's deception if you
can see the book here
it is nothing but there was deception
let me tell you why promise is very
important against book is very very
important you know why because the
shaytan comes to you in a variety of
ways yeah he's going to come and try to
hit you with
[ __ ] social partners you can't do that
innovation
if not innovation in the religion major
sins not major sin is going to come to
you with minor sins not minus is going
to come to you
with what is going to occupy you with
things that are playing all day
you know playing stuff all day but you
could be doing something better you can
be queried in the quran yeah or you can
do both but you know excessive
thing or doing occupying you with the
lesser of two because you want to go and
give in charity
he stops you and says you know why don't
you read qur'an maybe i don't know i'm
just giving argument's secret
because otherwise reward may be greater
or vice versa
shaitan's ultimate goal is what he is
destined to
hell he wants to imagine guys if you are
destined to hell
yeah and and and allah gave him the
choice by the way he didn't himself here
you are going to want to take it please
wants to take anybody there with him but
he doesn't care
he's like someone like imagine a cat
who's got his claws on you
whatever he can take rather little i
don't care whatever as he's going
he wants to take whatever from you this
is his main objective in god and that's
what allah says
shaytan is an enemy and take him as an
enemy
brothers and sisters how many of us have
enemies we don't like and we're very
appreciative you know he might come and
do this or man
what about shaytan you let go of him and
this is the reason why brothers and
sisters what nasdale is saying here
and brother steve harvey was all like
due respect i
genuinely respect him as a man genuinely
someone that i'm like wow i like his
principles
and what he lives by yeah even corny's
name uh son's name ali etc
and it's beautiful but there's a reality
that we need to be
uh aware of i can come to and make this
video um and be like you know what it's
all hunky-dory yes whoa yes
hold hands there's multiple ways there
is no more multiple ways to heaven
there isn't now but let me make
something clear islam is the only
religion steve harvey happens to watch
this video
islam is the only religion that says
allah does not punish a nation until he
sends a messenger
islam is the only religion that says if
somebody hasn't heard the message of
islam
they are not accountable and they will
be judged on the day of judgment with a
special test
because allah allah has negated when you
study his asmr
his names and attributes he negated
oppression to himself he will never
oppress anyone
you have this predestiny and free will
so let's make that very clear however if
somebody doesn't know the message of
islam at
all at all and he dies in that state of
course there's a chance so as muslims
there is a chance listen carefully
a christian a pagan an atheist a a a
a buddhist a a christian or a jew a
potential of entering paradise yes
but as long as they did not hear the
message of islam but if they heard the
message of islam
and they know it to be true and they say
oh
no but you know that's a different story
now because now that is
in the context of you know it's the
truth but you're covering you're like
so guys this is what we're trying to say
inshaallah and i hope that has benefited
you because when i saw his videos i said
i need to touch up on this
we asked allah subhanahu wa steve harvey
he would be an amazing
example as a muslim because he has those
principles and i don't know if
abu bakr who said that but he said those
who subhanallah
had certain traits in comfort in
disbelief when they come to islam
it beautifies yeah you can see that it
will they'll become so much more amazing
so i just wanted to share that with you
a video with you guys hope you guys
benefited
and robin sisters please do not be
deceived by the shaytan allah said he's
made the religion clear
islam is the truth and islam has been
there from day one so let's not
water it down and make it seem like yeah
we all hold hands this is nothing but a
deception
you know if if nas daily um you know
god forbid if he dies in how we in this
state
and he is in front of god and allah asks
him why didn't you follow islam
he can't say oh no and i thought there's
different ways subhanallah
do we take like okay nasty allah asking
on what
did you say that or what what basis and
one of the biggest synthesis talk about
allah that
he is not affirmed he has not said for
himself just as they say jesus is good
he's the son of god so let's be careful
inshallah and hope this benefit is a
reminder some of you guys might wish to
be like oh you're ruining the whole
video i'm so sorry i have to be real you
want to be fake
i'm sorry i can't you know we have to be
just and that is what i wanted to do
so we asked allah guides that steve
harvey and his wife and his children
inshallah until next time
assalamualaikum